Because communication is a physical art form. It needs to be learned physically.
I have a stack of Lego blocks.
I have a whole little stack of post-it notes here.
And if you work with someone who is a relentless fast talker,
let me tell you how not to help them say, Hey, listen, Andrew, that was great.
You did a great job tonight, but listen, next time, just,
just talk a little slower. Doesn't help.
I'm sure you know why that doesn't help cause you're not in your head,
but it doesn't because the person you've not given them anything actionable,
even more so you're not giving them anything physical or kinesthetic they can
hang on to. So instead we often say to people, take a Lego block,
say one idea at the end of that idea in silence stack this Lego block
until it clicks in place with the next one, then pick up another block.
Say the next idea at the end of that idea,
stack the Lego block again in silence. Next idea. Lego block.
Next idea. Lego block. You can do a post-it notes too.
They're easier to transport and most folks have post-it notes.
But what you're doing there is you're forcing a change in terms of
how their physical communication instrument is working.
You're giving them almost a muscle interruption because people who relentless
speak quickly,
especially in interviews and they feel like I've got to get all the information
out as fast as I can. And they begin to stumble over their words because of it.
That's a muscle memory habit. So in fact,
they can even practice forcing themselves to actually insert a pause,
share one idea at a time. And the weird,
cool thing about remote communication and not everything about remote
communication is cool.
But one of the things that is good is we actually have this weird little
boundary right here. I call this the cloak of invisibility.
I'm wiggling my hands. I'm still wiggling them. Andrew. Whoa.
Now I'm moving them still, but they're still wiggling.
So people can actually use kinesthetic training to try to force them to change
some of their habits.
Wow. Yeah, they could cheat.
This is some cheating stuff here.
Like I can putting Legos
together with my hands and you can't see it. I'm kidding. I mean,
this is actually, I will say I do a lot of zooming,
which is probably not shocking to people right now,
but a lot of the time your hands are not visible.
And so I'm doing stuff like I'll do stuff with my hands. Do not the Lego thing,
but like I'll so I, I love it. Uh,
so you can use a physical activity to kind of adjust yourself.
Yeah. And it sounds wacky. It's not, it's actually called embodied cognition.
So that's a big,
fancy scientific term for it basically means you're learning something by doing,
getting information from your body, not just your brain,
because a lot of the habits that people go into,
they're fundamentally not in control of. They get anxious, they stop breathing.
They stopped breathing.
Their mind gets a bit panicked because their cells on a cellular level are
telling your brain you're drowning because no oxygen is coming into the system.
So they feel like I'm drowning. What? That does speed up heart rate.
The heart starts pumping faster. Big muscle groups start getting recruited.
Small muscle groups lock up.
It's like a little bunny rabbit and the headlights of a car.
And then in that state, what they're telling themselves is like,
say something smart, say something smart, say something smart.
And then inevitably they don't. And then they say like, Oh,
you're such an idiot. Why didn't you say a smart thing? So.
I said that to myself an awful lot. No, I'm kidding.
Well, what did you say? I mean, I know, I mean,
I've definitely been there many times in my life. Um,
I I'd actually think say one of the biggest things about running for president
and adapting was not doing that because I think my natural tendency
earlier in life was to, uh,
Monday morning quarterback, myself or whatnot and be like, Oh,
we should have done this. Should've done that.
One of the things that I had to get better at was essentially
not beating myself up.
But it is, it's very related to actually, I mean,
in a way this drill I'm talking about right now, it's exact same thing,
which is you're in the middle of some thought you can feel it's going badly.
I'm saying dumb stuff. This is not going well. I'm on a tangent, Oh crap.
Where am I going? But building that muscle memory discipline,
you force yourself to stop, finish that thought.
And you know what, I'm going to start a fresh on this next thought,
because what tends to happen is people hit the gas pedal and things go South.
And then the whole vicious cycle kicks in. So it's actually the same thing,
but just on a, almost a sentence by sentence or thought by thought basis,
as opposed to an entire media event when you're on the campaign trail.
Um,
are there other examples of physical activities if I've got a different issue?
Yeah.
Yeah, for sure. So I got this cork, it's a wine cork.
You're going to slice it into slivers. This is the tool that's very old.
This idea. This principle goes all the way back to ancient Greece,
an orator named DeMoss, Denise,
who would practice speaking with an impediment in his mouth.
And I learned this from the head of voice and speech at the Royal Shakespeare
company in London that guide him, Andrew Wade.
When I studied with him at the Guthrie theater in Minnesota. Anyway,
that's the pedigree of it.
But all you do is talk with the impediment in between your teeth like that.
Now I have updated this for Corona virus times,
which people don't want to put stuff in their mouth or on their face,
which makes sense, bad idea.
So instead I've been coaching folks to use this because they do put this in
their mouth two times a day.
So for the folks who get on zoom calls and they begin to get all mealy mouth and
they stumble over their words and as they do that,
they feel bad about what they're saying.
So they talk even faster and they close her mouth more as a close her mouth,
more than words come out, even worse.
And they begin to stumble even more as opposed to critiquing yourself
negatively about that and falling all back in that thought suppression trap.
Instead,
I just have to practice freaking with a toothbrush between their teeth
two times a day,
and no warning spit up a toothpaste fractures with a tooth fry for 60
seconds. And in the, the same thing, because what you're doing,
just like a swimmer who puts on a couple of extra swimsuits in the practice
pool. So they increase the drag and they're faster in the actual meat.
What you're doing is you're making your muscles jobs harder. So these muscles,
they're not used to communicating in a really dynamic, really dexterous,
really forceful way. And you're building stronger muscles by doing that.
So that's one that's about enunciation, diction and clarity. That's like.
Putting weights on when you're walking or what, uh, wow.
Just restricting your communication muscles. Um,
fascinating. Okay.
There's one for what I call linguistic precision. And all that means is,
are you saying what you want to be saying or not?
So like lots and lots of people, again, back to thought suppression,
they get off the stage. Someone says that was great, but listen, you know,
some staffer comes up to them with a, with a clipboard, they say,
but next time just say a couple fewer ums.
It looked like you were kind of stammering on that one answer.
So just try not to say, um, just pause in the stead.
So that sounds like good feedback, right?
Cause you've been given an actionable thing pause instead of saying I'm okay,
fine. Does it work? No, because all the person's doing is thinking about the,
um, which by the way, is not actually that big of a deal.
People are weirdly quite forgiving of filler language.
It exists on a bit of a hockey stick curve.
So people don't really notice it until they do. And then once they do,
it becomes more and more problematic, but it's actually pretty forgiving.
So the bigger problem though, is that people get focused on it themselves.
So what they're going to actually play around with is a drill I've created
called finger walking.
And all people have to do is walk their fingers across their desk or
table,
like so forcing themselves to choose each and every single
word that they share, once they've reached the end of one,
thought they can move their hand back to the front of the desk or so,
but not until they've completed that idea.
So the point here is that filler language is not a problem. It's a symptom,
it's a symptom of you not being in as much charge of what you're saying as you
could be. And the problem is not the arm.
The problem is you're not being as precise as you could be with all the other
words, but just thinking that is not enough,
the activity of actually using embodied cognition to commit
to each and every single word helps people focus in a physical way on the
language they're choosing,
as opposed to the little filler words they're trying to avoid.
So that's something focused on linguistic precision saying smart stuff,
saying it in a very accurate and precise way.
This is something you could do in the zoom era,
because you could do the walking with your fingers,
choosing every single word deliberately and just do it on your leg without
anyone seeing.
Yeah. And then people will say like, you can't do that in real life.
And I'm like, yeah, you can. Yeah, you can,
you can do that a few minutes a day and you're going to build muscle memory and
you know what?
It will be faster than the last 10 years when you've been telling yourself,
like stop saying, um, what I get stop saying, stop saying, stop saying, um,
that didn't work pretend years. So don't do that anymore.
Do this instead a little bit and build some muscle memory.
So those are a couple examples of this approach of kinesthetic learning and
embodied cognition to build on the delivery side of things,
positive communication habits that help unlock both smart stuff and smart stuff
delivered. Well,
I want to give folks one more tool in terms of a kinesthetic approach to change
something, because it can be very valuable.
And I think you might actually have something to share about it because of what
it helps people do, which is taking your time before answering questions.
So I often have people keep like a wiffle ball or something like that on the
desk. And actually when they get a question asked of them,
roll the ball forward and let it roll back to them.
And then answer the question. Now do that on low consequence calls. I mean,
like you're just chit chatting with your friends about stuff,
but you're building the discipline of tolerating.
The thinking time it takes to come up with something that you want to share.
I even recommend that people do that even when they don't need it.
So you might get the question in the interview of like, you know,
tell me about your experience in your last job.
And you actually know everything you want to say,
but simply by giving yourself some more latitude,
some more thinking time before you begin,
what you do is you're giving yourself that margin of safety for when you get the
question that you really don't know what to say,
because you will have built already a track record of taking your time as you
move through these answers.
So that's a little way people can internalize that habit of pausing before you
speak.
One thing I can say with authority is that whatever timeframe you think you're
pausing, it's actually much, much shorter than that. You know what I mean?
So it might that you like you,
like you're pausing for several seconds,
but it's probably significantly less than that. Uh,
it's just when you're in that mode of answering a question,
even a second seems like an eternity.
So you actually can just let that moment breathe and just seem like
you're reflecting.
They've measured this by the way.
I mean speakers in high consequence situations,
they can be off by up to 10 X of what they're, you know,
I keep a sticky on my computer here to show clients,
which is this equation right there. And you see that equation.
P is not R.
Yeah. Any guesses on the, the a words.
They're not reality is my, there you.
Go. Yeah. Perception is not reality and speakers.
Oftentimes in high consequence situations, there'll be off by up to 10 X.
So they think a pause is 10 seconds and it was a one second. And you know,
technology can help in this actually. So like,
if you're going to be interviewing record yourself, talking, look back,
and then actually the little sound wave thing on the voice,
a voice memos app will show you notice how long your pauses you're right.
I promise you, it's probably at least three times shorter than you think it is.
Probably.
I guess I got used to this on the trail where you can
pause to reflect and you realize that it's only a second and it's
completely natural sounding and whatnot. And no,
no one thinks you're just sitting there stressed, trumping your chin whiskers,
thinking about it. Yeah.
Yeah. But see,
that goes back to that initial principle I'm talking about of being other
focused. So like your friend comes to you, your friends in a crisis,
they ask you what to do.
You wouldn't feel some sort of artificial countdown clock of,
I better start talking because otherwise I won't look like I know what I'm
talking about. You would just sit there for a moment, take it,
and then begin to share your thoughts as precisely and as helpfully
as you could. Because in that moment, you're thinking about one thing,
which is what should I say to this person right now to help this person.
And that's where that pause would come from a deeply organic place.
Pausing comes from two things, two things alone, one,
you need some time to think about what you want to say next or two.
You want to give the person you're talking to time to digest what you just said.
So it's not as though it's too short or too long.
It is about you actually tolerating the time it takes to figure out what you
want to say next. And that simple ball drill is a good way to make it again,
very kinesthetic.
So people actually forced themselves to do it because if they try to
maintain a pause like that, they're not going to do it.
They're going to think they paused for four seconds and it will have been half
of a second.
Yes. Half of a second, uh, high stakes situations,
interviewer camera in your face, et cetera.
I really suggest for people to try to embrace a growth mindset
about communication. You can learn how to pause.
You can learn how to enunciate better.
You can learn how to be more precise with your language, their skills,
just like a sport or a musical instrument that one can practice.
And the reason that's so important is because it puts some power back into the
person's hands. It's a skill you can improve. And as you do,
so you'll reap the rewards of doing that. Even just a sense of command of, wow,
I actually am in command of some of these things.
As a parent, we know a growth mindset is the key to life. Really? You know,
if your kid's like, Oh, I'm bad at that being like, well, you know,
you can get better because you can get better at just about anything.
If you decide to put some time and energy into it.
Thank you for listening in. I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If you did,
please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know every time we have a
new episode.